I just want to say I am a huge fan of
the John Wick franchise and it is
awesome sorry for my language to
talk to you guys uh love this movie love
the franchise you guys have both done so
many things in your career what does it
actually mean to both of you to be part
of a franchise like this that resonates
with so many people around the world but
for me it's just I'm just kind of um
was two things first of all I'm just
amazed that it's gotten to this point
because it started as such a small and
almost independent film that I wasn't
sure was going to be much more than a
maybe a cult hit that I knew was just a
great script uh that turned into a this
Juggernaut so the fact that I'm part of
such a such a not just such a big
franchise but such a big big franchise
that's so
so well done and it literally changed
action films and then created a world
that you never that you've never seen
before uh it's amazing to me and then
the fact that I've been fortunate enough
in my career to have had that experience
particularly television more than once
so I'm just kind of damn this is my
career this is cool you never know I
mean I've been you know doing this
business a long time but the very long
time you never know what's gonna happen
with a movie all I know is that there
was a tight movie the first one was
great look to the cast it was going to
be fun New York Thanksgiving five year
perfect
because a lot of things to be taken
consideration when you do a movie
location you know weather time of year
well it's just just not the script
but and then suddenly here we are you
know five films later including the
ballerina which we both did last year
but I mean it's you know it's it's been
thrilling it's exciting I love it the
cast is good okay
um the the two people who were but I
must say responsible I think
a Keanu and Chad
in terms of the continuity agreed I'm in
terms of either chance never done I'm
sure you've been offered a zillion other
movies but he's kept to this and he's
refined this it was a difficult thing to
refine and expand you know the world has
got bigger every time but it all seems
to be logical within it the films seem
to be you know and they look beautiful
too they've got even more gorgeous to
look at and the sort of balletic
assassination
um sort of you know about the symbolic
assessment the balletic quality of the
kineticism of the of the action is
extraordinary to look at and at the same
time there's also a film within their
phone when it's like I said before but
like you know keanu's like it's as if
they put somebody's head and said Wanted
Dead or Alive and all these assassins
come from everywhere all over the world
for the pleasure of fighting John Wick
which is an underlying part of the movie
which is a kind of a an interesting
thing about this world by the hotel so
there is a sort of continuity and this
and a a compelling sort of yeah it's a
world which has been carefully thought
out you mentioned ballerina I know that
it takes place between Wick three and
yeah and I'm just curious what can you
tease it with do you guys have a small
role is it a camp is it a good role like
what can you I don't know much about
that especially similar chaos in it too
well I mean we have both I mean but
they're old cameos in it basically
throughout probably through the movie
he's just dotted a little more but it's
like and she was great during her
election no she was terrific and it's so
much it's it's uh our our our
participation it is so much about uh
helping to uh for the audience connect
that it's part of the same world yeah on
that note I already have to rap I'm just
going to say thank you so much for uh
making these films